il
merci mots pour cette belle présentation
le lebouc comptable mais ça au début ça
vient d'inscrire les gens vous savoir
mettre un défi exceptionnel à une
présentation je pense car région on voit
trop petit on est pris dans des secteurs
industriels secteur évidemment des
ressources naturelles qui prend beaucoup
de place si on a de la difficulté à se
détacher le sol comme si le passé était
nécessairement garant du futur
tous ont un coût d'opportunité important
on pense on se concentre sur ce qu'on
connaît qui pendant ce temps là il ya
plein de choses qui nous fait l'an
clément paix d'options techno fils en
cm1 ont reçu finalement collectivement
décidé avant même d'avoir été en mesure
d'en d'avenir sied pays
on tue des entrepreneurs dans l'oeuf il
faut se défaire nos paradigmes il faut
se propulser vers l'avant le monde peut
nous appartenir à nous aussi
ici en région comme n'importe où sa
planète
le district la cdapp change trois
concepts importants pour arriver à sauf
le premier l'ambition deuxième
créativité et 3e finalement l'exécution
et ça ça crée de la magie on ne parlait
quelques reprises ce soir de la magie je
pense qu'on arrive au milieu de ces
trois éléments là on a de la magie qui
opère et on peut faire ce qu'on veut ici
en abitibi témiscamingue
on va commencer par l'ambition à
l'électrique à palerme archi d'affection
façon pour nous trouver
il ya d'abord il ya d'abord ce collectif
est ce que objectivement on peut ici
conquérir le monde peu importe le
secteur industriel où on est bien
probable guen jadeyaoui c'est bon ça
problème le mcee une époque la réponse
objective assauts étaient non mais
aujourd'hui c'est oui hier ce week end
la société est engagée dans un processus
de virtualisation
il ya des choses le monde est à notre
portée la distance est de moins en moins
importante et c'est plus en plus facile
de faire des affaires peu importe le
secteur industriel où on est à partir
d'ici nous on a un paquet de clients de
fournisseurs qui sont partout ça plein
air qui même si on n'est pas en contact
avec eux de façon physique on est en
relation d'affaires avec oeil cette
extraordinaire on a des fournisseurs qui
viennent de partout après il ya
l'ambition cette fois-ci individuelle et
ça ça dépend beaucoup de chaque individu
à la question est ce que je suis prêt à
assumer le risque évidemment chaque
personne a sa propre réponse en fonction
de son bagage son expertise en fonction
d'où il vient en fonction son milieu
familial mais je peux vous assurer une
chose je peux vous assurer que si votre
famille
si vos amis si votre entourage votre
milieu professionnel et vous supporte
avec vous des fois vous avez capable dé
réaliser qui va y avoir plus
d'entrepreneurs
oui
équipe réactivité la créativité pour moi
c'est le deuxième facteur d'abord pour
avoir un succès une idée intéressante
d'un point de vue à faire il faut
trouver une solution créative un besoin
qui est généralisé
internet nous donne un choc plus
aujourd'hui pour faire ça avec internet
on a accès à toutes la même information
en temps réel peu importe où en est
qu'on soit ici à new york ou à shanghai
maintenant faut y ajouter une dose de
créativité même si on a une solution ces
dépôts créative ça va être difficile et
on est des filles à porter comme un
adulte on est pris dans nos paradigmes
et il faut absolument sortir de tout ça
pour hervé créatif que je veux vous
rappeler c'est quand vous étiez enfant
que j'ai cherché dans votre ligne soir
tout ce qui lui passait dans la tête
tous qui avait caché en dessous de votre
lit ou dans le garde-robe puis moi je me
rappelle l'autre je le sais je vous dis
mérite-t-elle pas jusqu'à l'âge de 13 14
ans je me cachais dépliant du lac
ouverte
cette attention pour pas qu'il ya un
orteil qui dépasse en disant que le pecq
quelque chose qui est croquer dedans
durant des nuits
c'était fantastique challenge de 13 14
ans aujourd'hui par des blocs lego c'est
même plus une activité créative
ça se fait en 48 états bongo adore faire
des blocs lego qui l'on vient de se
montrer qu'ils pouvaient faire d'autres
choses que de suivre les 48 états pour
faire ce qu'ils voulaient vrai bloc
légaux meilleur moyen que j'ai trouvé
pour se tirer ma créativité c'est
d'accoler des concepts ensemble des
concepts qui à la base ne m'a rien à
voir je vous donne l exemple j'ai
rencontré un type qui a une chocolaterie
et que pris un concept finalement vieux
comme le monde ou fondue au chocolat
quand de conserve
il ya mis son ensemble du baume succès
commercial
troisième et dernier facteur l'exécution
même si on est ambitieux même si on a
des solutions créatives un problème que
généraliser si on n'est pas capable
d'élaborer et d'exécuter une stratégie
on est on est pas de projet on n'a rien
d'autre que patente une invention mais
sans succès commercial les deux paires
manque que moi j'ai observé au niveau de
l'exécution c'est toujours la vérité
la vente marketing et la capacité
d'action pour l'aspect marketing le coup
et l'énergie que ça prend pour rendre
les nouveaux produits au marché est
toujours sous-évalué dans tous les
projets que j'ai vu que j'en ai vu
travailler avec des partenaires
stratégiques ça n'apparaît la meilleure
solution il faut s'associer avec du
monde commence les marchés sont capables
de prendre votre produit fait leur
entrée dans le marché pour une
entreprise au final si il est pas
capable d'agir si elle est pas dans
l'action
elle sera pas capable de se développer à
soit pas capable de passer de notre état
et ça on ne monte pas ça dans les écoles
sans action pas de résultats sans
résultat pas d'entreprise
ouais même plus besoin
il ya quelques personnes qui ont fait
leurs méthodes d'un groupe site qui vous
montre un peu ce que ce que moi j'avais
dollar quand je réfléchisse un peu
manquant surtout des mba je t'ai je vais
développer une capacité vraiment
extraordinaire j'étais capable de
prendre une problématique simple et la
rendent complexe 400e des hautes plaines
d'outils peuplingues appris plein de
choses peut-être les utiliser fait que
la petite folie m 6 1 puis tu appliques
des choses puis la rx le botlan registre
le port jeune mes partenaires d'affaires
qui me dit toujours selon tan aliz ben
trop faute soit plus dans l'action moi
je pense que lui est né laisse passer
mais ça c'est une autre affaire sent pas
ça c'est un arbre décisionnel pour faire
des tos le battre
aussi la vigueur et la constance il
apparaît comme essentiel dans
l'exécution ce soit avec nos parents nos
amis nos familles dans le milieu des
affaires dans mieux personnel en
conclusion parce qu'on est vraiment
capable de conquérir le monde à partir
du 6 on a tout ce qu'il faut et ce juste
d'être à la fois ambitieux créatif est
capable d'exécuter ya ce week-end merci